now I don't profess to be the biggest
sporting fan however each year I can't
help but catch a dose of Wimbledon fever
Murray Federer and Nadal yes please I
must admit that's as much for their
shorts as their serve however when it
comes to women's tennis I can't even
begin to describe how much the Williams
sisters inspire me so I never thought
they'd come a day when I'd be cheering
teenage newcomer coco Gough for beating
Venus in straight sets overnight we had
a new tennis sensation the press
couldn't get enough of this young
challenger who was inspired to play by
the very woman she beat but once my
euphoria began to wear off I started to
question if this was right or even moral
as a society we understand the value of
maturity and the wisdom it brings in
most areas of life is it really fair for
a 15 year old to be playing in an adult
tournament so while we celebrate this
new tennis sensation let's also take a
moment to reflect on the kind of
pressure we are mounting on her very
young shoulders I mean in certain sports
this has always been the case I mean I
once remember a long time ago making a
poem about gymnastics where kids were
literally taking from an incredibly
young age and actually when you talk to
them some of them had really damaged by
it when the 15 and if any mature of 15
is too young I don't know let's look at
what she actually says okay even if I
the restrictions weren't there I still
think I wouldn't play like as much as
players do when the older players do you
just because I'm still trying to develop
my game I'm still trying to Train I mean
what could be in issues it is the
woman's turn her into a superstar yes
she hasn't yet got either the age but
might not have the talent and it will be
interesting to see them will we look
back in five years time and say what
happened to her and and that's my point
cuz I think with a lot of other sports
there is an age limit you know we know
that with football you are you doing
your under six
Dean's athletics at 17 I think and and
and an even golfer has an age
restriction and I wonder I just think
it's a lot when you look at the kind of
attention that was put on her overnight
is someone that young able to handle it
can I just bring in a video then I'll
bring you in Carol let's see at her
dad's bar when she won what happened
[Applause]
I mean it's wonderful but that's a lot
Majan way to return to school just it's
interesting John McEnroe I heard him
being interviewed this weekend he said
he thought it was really good that she
went out when she did and his words were
enough already what he meant was of the
pressure of the celebrity and let's just
let's just read quote from he said I
remember my first one more than I was 18
I got to the semi as it sounds so ever
whelming but felt like it was almost
better than I didn't win that I'd have
time to sort out figure it out
understand what it would be like to be a
pro on to and give myself as it turned
out a year before I turn pro Cory Golf
has to be handled very carefully that's
the key thing she's going to be an
unbelievable champion but we don't want
to overwhelm her too soon my gran and I
saw in that very last match she paid the
joy of the previous games the exuberance
it wasn't there
she wasn't handling the setbacks very
well and that that was her agent but
that Sid III don't think there should be
a nadir because I think sport is all
about competition it's all about
handling pressure it's all about winning
and how to handle losing and I think she
would have learned very valuable lessons
last week and she can only play another
five five more tournaments in the next
year so it is gonna be handled for her
Nick I want to bring an aligned
challenge or Hawkeye and what you've
just said or whatever it's called
because you said we are we are mounting
the pressure on her very young well if
you turn up at Wimbledon or the French
Open or Flushing Meadow New York where
that's there's not we're not forcing
Wimbledon is it saying you had to play
and there are rules just so we get some
things out this is the restrictions that
are in place players aged 13 in younger
cannot play professional tournaments
players aged 14 to 17 are allowed to
play a limited number of events which
increases each year male players can
play in any number of professional tours
from the age of 16 female players can
play in any number of professional
performance from the age of 18 and we
thank the Association for tennis
professionals and women's tennis
association players for those
researchers you can when I offer I say
it she's obviously a phenomenal ton of
this age what are you going to do not
let her play for another couple of years
no no what I'm saying is I wonder if
talent at that age should be playing
each other that's what I'm saying I
don't think they should be playing
adults and all
would add to that is part of the reason
she got all the attention she got is
because she's 15 if she was 19 and she
be sorry of Venus and Strait says I
don't think we'd be as excited and I
just think it's a lot we love precocious
talent we love the fact that in some
senses England footballers are 18 or 19
it's found that playing against blows at
27 well firstly I can't like on remarks
those girls get away with murder because
if you two chaps have done an intro like
that where you said oh I like tennis
ball I admit I'll admit it's more for
the girls skirts you would have been in
trouble so you gallows for well said
anyway I can say right moving on from
that I find it interesting the rules
that you've just mentioned the
restrictions on how many tournaments
they can play when they're young I'm in
two months about that because it's I
understand that you're trying to
restrict to avoid burnout but to me that
would stack more pressure on the limited
number of tournaments they can do and I
was interested because if you're if you
know you're only allowed to do I don't
know let's just say four tournaments
let's just say and you only got four
let's just imagine you and your fourth
one you know that is it got a winner
yeah whereas they've actually you're
just doing what you want you can do over
that fourth tournament it's not so much
pressure for you so I'm in two minds
about them and I think it's really
interesting when we talk about the
pressure on young people Ellie SATA the
the snowboarder she very tragically took
her own life on her 18th birthday and
her father has spoken out a lot about
the pressure that's put on to young
athletes and it wanted or enough to
handle it yeah and in my mind is I've
got a question do we need children to be
competing professionally but you
disagree but listen you heard her talk
there this girl has got a head on her
shoulders Laura Robson remember Lawson
who was the big noise of women about
three years ago she said I totally
understand why the moon is there for the
amount of games to play and there have
been bad examples in the past of kids
burning out too young and I don't think
that's going to happen to Coker because
she's got great parents I think it's
crazy that she's only going to be able
to play five more turn-ins
professionally
until her birthday next year she is
saying no letter fit she's saying you
can't grow as a player and get the
experience you need if you don't can I
say we wouldn't have a child prodigy
working in Goldman Sachs
have a math fifteen-year-old match
genius working at Google why are we all
right honestly saying you know better
than her mom or dad I'm not I'm doing
speculative you are let the parents
parent the child if they think she's up
one of the things that concerned me when
I was involved in football I mean that
you're literally now professional
Premier League clubs are taking kids at
the age of six yeah yeah and they're
being let and for ten years they are
being told you are wonderful you're
going to be there cars picking them up
taking them there doing this earth yeah
and suddenly most of them 16 17 18 it
kicked out and you wonder what happens
to them and the damage that does and a
lot of these kids like this girl won't
make it let's just if we look at what
her father at Corey Goff has said I went
through everybody I thought was relevant
that won grand slams and were good young
I went through every one of their
situations and looked at where they were
at a certain age what they were doing I
asked a lot of questions because I was
concerned about burnout am i doing the
right things which again speaks to the
parent jin-joo and that's the thing
what did Morris Becker it wasn't a 15
when he came he was he won win within a
time I think he was 17 he was unseeded
in one win would because he went on to
be bonking bhavish and all sorts of
other words Boris would that be